НАБУ чекало початку роботи суду? Чому так?
Кримінальні провадження на сьогодні не надійшли.
Кого би хотів президент першим бачити за ґратами?
Ніяких розмов не було! Несподіване запитання....
- Хабарі?
- Борони боже!
5-го вересня нарешті запрацював Вищий антикорупційний суд України.
Про те, як працюватиме суд і за які перші справи
проти корупціонерів візьметься, говоримо з головою
Вищого антикорупційного суду України Оленою Танасевич.
- Доброго дня.
- Доброго дня, Катерино!
Розкажіть, чи все готове для роботи Вищого антикорупційного суду?
Насправді шлях до становлення ВАСУ є непростим.
Однак, ми його подолали.
З травня по вересень 2019 року
працівниками апарату ВАСУ і суддями було зроблено
надзвичайний обсяг роботи. Було отримано три приміщення,
в цих приміщеннях були проведені ремонтні роботи,
які дозволили розташувати судову установу в зазначених будівлях,
було сформовано апарат ВАСУ
і проведені тендерні закупівлі обладнання, меблів.
В українського суспільства величезні очікування і бажання
того, щоб корупціонери сиділи за ґратами.
Як я розумію, технічно проблем немає з тим,
щоб суд почав працювати на повну?
Ті приміщення, які призначені для відвідувачів,
ті які призначені для проведення судового розгляду кримінальних проваджень,
для роботи слідчих суддів, для роботи суддів апеляційної палати -
вони повністю готові. Збори суддів обрали шістьох слідчих суддів,
які здійснюватимуть судовий контроль за дотриманням
прав і  свобод людини на стадії досудового розслідування,
сформовано сім колегій ВАСУ першої інстанції
і чотири колегії в апеляційній палаті для апеляційного перегляду рішень суду першої інстанції.
Пані Олено, за які справи суд буде братись найперше?
Насправді питання щодо пріоритетності справ
у суді ніколи не постає,
тому що кожна справа пріоритетна,
якщо йдеться про технічні моменти,
то за хронологічним надходженням справ
вони будуть розподілятися автоматично і передаватись колегіям.
Зараз НАБУ передало вам справи?
Поки що ні.
НАБУ просто чекало офіційного початку роботи суду чи чому так?
Офіційний початок це 5 вересня 2019 року,
в принципі з 9-ої години ранку цього дня
до нас вже повинні надходити матеріали.
Однак треба розуміти, що
ці матеріали мають бути підготовлені для передачі їх до суду,
заходять вже клопотання, заходять вже подання до слідчих суддів,
однак ще кримінальних проваджень на сьогодні не надійшли.
Зараз Ви не бачили жодної справи проти жодного топ-корупціонера?
Ще не надійшли провадження.
В інтерв’ю, яке президент України Володимир Зеленський дав нещодавно
актору Станіславу Боклану, він сказав про те,
що вже призначений Генеральний прокурор,
що вже восени починає роботу Антикорупційний суд,
тож перші посадки слід чекати вже восени.
Якщо дозволите, то я дещо виправлю запитання.
Мені здається що у сфері кримінальної юстиції
немає місця для жартів та влучних висловів
і тому варто говорити про обвинувальні вироки,
за якими передбачене покарання у вигляді позбавлення волі.
Якщо йдеться про обвинувальні вироки, про строки їх ухвалення,
то одразу можу зазначити,
що передбачити строк розгляду кримінального провадження в суді неможливо.
Адже цей строк залежить від колегії судів,
а від багатьох факторів.
Кількості обвинуваченних: чим їх більше тим складніша справа,
від кількості епізодів з якими це обвинувачення прив’язане,
чим їх більше, тим складніша справа
і тим потрібен більший час для того, щоб її розглянути,
цей строк також залежить від кількості доказів і від видів доказів.
Коли йдеться, до прикладу, про результати негласних слідчих розшукових дій,
оли здійснювався запис розмов, наприклад,
і цей запис триває понад 20 годин,
то очевидно суд зобов'язаний дослідити кожен доказ,
а деякі, суд досліджує двічі, повторно,
тому говорити про строки розгляду кримінальних проваджень я не можу.
Я не вмію передбачати майбутнє.
Ми бачимо що президент України прагне
пришвидшити роботу Верховної ради,
ми бачимо, що Верховна Рада працює і вночі,
тобто очевидно, що він хоче, аби були результати одразу.
Чи відчуваєте Ви що таким чином може чинитись тиск на суд?
Щоб справді перші вироки були восени?
І щоб можна було показати, що в країні почалась боротьба з корупціонерами.
У мене такого відчуття немає - щодо можливого тиску на суддів ВАСУ.
Ви зустрічались з Володимиром Зеленським?
Так на початку червня.
Розкажіть про зустріч, як пройшла? Які враження?
Враження цілком позитивні. Темою цієї зустрічі було
забезпечення ВАСУ  приміщеннями,
і за результатами зустрічі
станом на теперішній час ВАСУ забезпечено тимчасовими трьома приміщеннями.
Одне з них - це вулиця Хрещатик 42 в Києві,
де будуть працювати слідчі суду,  це Хрестовий провулок, 4а,
в Києві, де буде працювати апеляційна палата ВАСУ
і це проспект Перемоги 41, де будуть працювати
судді першої інстанції, що будуть розглядати
кримінальні провадження по суті  і тому я вважаю,
що наша зустріч із паном президентом
є прикладом взаємодії  між органами державної влади
дуже такий зразковий я б сказала.
Це була лише одна зустріч?
Це була одна зустріч.
Жодних дзвінків і розмов.
Офіційне запрошення стало результатом
звернення голови ВАСУ.
Офіційна зустріч і офіційний результат.  Жодних дзвінків не було.
Не було розмов про те, кого б президент хотів
перишим бачити за гратами з топ-корупціонерів?
Ні, таких розмов не було, несподіване запитання.
Здається, що у Володимира Зеленського особливе ставлення
до попереднього президента Петра Порошенка,
чи може він бути в списку тих, хто
може опинитися за ґратами як корупціонер?
Я не вмію передбачати  майбутнє.
Я не можу надати коментар будь-який . Він буде недоречним.
Пані Олено,  Вас обрали головою суду в травні,
і багато активістів, зокрема Центру протидії корупції критикували,
що навіщо дана для початку роботи суду пауза в 4 місяці.
Оскільки станом на весну вже лежали справи проти топ-корупціонерів.
Зокрема про Геннадія Труханова, мера Одеси
якого звинувачували в розкраданні бюджету міста.
Це 92 мільйони гривень...
І за цей час його справа була закрита.
Що може відбуватись з подібними справами з топ-корупціонерами,
які були протягом літа так швидко закриті судами? Вони можуть повернутись?
Мені складно надавати будь-які коментарі
щодо тих проваджень, які я взагалі не бачила.
А коли я ці матеріали і провадження побачу,
тоді я за кодексом суддівської етики буду позбавлена надавати будь-який коментар.
Тому, мабуть, це запитання залишається без відповіді.
Президент Зеленський подав зміни до закону -
йдеться про незаконне збагачення,
і за новою нормою сума збагачення за яку починається кримінальна відповідальність,
зросла у 15 разів.
Якщо раніше це було близько 1 млн гривень,
то зараз йдеться про 12 чи 15.
І депутати, зокрема Олександра Устінова, яка писала про це,
говорить, що таким чином багато топ-корупціонерів
просто будуть поза дією закону і кримінальної відповідальності.
Що ви скажете на це?
Я вважаю, що будь-яка норма закону вона повинна виконуватись.
Будь-який законопроект, я вважаю,
недоречно коментувати чи обговорювати
представнику судової гілки влади,
якщо законодавець ухвалить законопроект в цій редації,
суд як будь- який інший орган державної влади,
як і будь-який інший громадянин, буде зобов'язаний його застосовувати.
Роботою НАБУ і так само НАЗК і САП не виправдала свої очікувань.
Як зміниться робота антикорупційних органів,
коли почне працювати ВАСУ?
Насправді робота органів досудового розслідування,
так само як і робота прокуратури, так само як і робота суду,
вона є надзвичайно складною і відповідальною,
і я вважаю, що вона заслуговує на повагу суспільства.
Чи зміниться робота цих органів
після того, як запрацює ВАСУ покаже час.
Ви зустрічались зі своїми колегами з цих органів?
Так звичайно, на спільних офіційних заходах.
Що обговорювалося?
Здебільшого обговорювали питання
щодо електронного документообігу - це наразі надзвичайно актуальне питання,
тому що воно б спростило значною мірою і пришвидшити
обмін документами між тими органами, які співпрацюють.
За ці 4 місяця очевидно багато хто з Вами хотів познайомитись.
Було багато дзвінків несподіваних для вас?
Насправді дзвінків несподіваних не було.
Можливо,  рівень моєї популярності перевищений.
Мені здається, що немає потреби відшукувати будь-які звязки з суддями.
Навіщо? Насправді розгляд кримінального провадження в суді  -
це територія протистояння між стороною захисту і стороною обвинувачення
і від якості їхньої роботи залежить результат.
Ви були суддею першої інстанції Печенізького суду Харківської області.
Тепер є головою такої важливої для країни інституції як Антикорупційний суд.
Що вас мотивувало піти на цю посаду?
Мотивувала ініціатива колег щодо того, щоб я зайняла цю посаду.
Я переконана у тому, що якщо твої колеги
або їх частина, бачить тебе керівником цієї установи -
то це велика честь і велика відповідальність.
Хотілося б створити суд який був би ідеальний за всіма параметрами,
щоб як судова установа він був зручний для працівників апарату,
для суддів для відвідувачів,
щоб розгляд справ відбувався з суворим дотриманням процесуального законодавства,
щоб ті рішення, які буде ухвалювати суд,
були найвищої якості.
Я думаю ця місія цілком здійсненна.
Які справи розглядали на своїй попередній роботі?
Всі категорії справ, серед них були кримінальні провадження, цивільні справи,
справи адміністративні і справи про адміністративні правопорушення.
Чи можете згадати випадки коли справді рішення давались непросто
і багато було сумнів?
Зазвичай до цієї категорії належать ті кримінальні провадження,
по яких передбачені покарання у вигляді позбавлення волі,
і до цих справ належать цивільні справи, які пов'язані з вирішенням долі дітей.
Це завжди складні справи в тому контексті,
що необхідно перевірити надзвичайно багато аспектів.
Хоча кожна справа є особливою.
Були погрози до Вас як до судді?
Бог милував.
Хабарі?
Борони боже!
В українського суспільства особливе ставлення до суддів,
що вони є повністю керовані і корумповані.
Що має змінитись, аби довіра до суду справді змінилась?
Як показують дослідження, зазвичай судам не довіряють ті громадяни,
які в судах ніколи не були.
За результатами опитування тих громадян,
які були учасниками процесу,
їхній рівень довіри значно вищий.
Тому я думаю, що було б дуже добре
правдиво висвітлювати роботи суддів,
зокрема і в ЗМІ, і надавати всю інформацію,
не тільки негативну, яка звичайно зустрічається,
але і ту позитивну інформацію, яка може охарактеризувати судову владу.
Серед суддів дуже багато
професійний вислококваліфікованих фахових людей.
Зарплата яка буде у суддів ВАСУ дозволяє бути незалежними?
Як на мене повністю дозволяє.
Станом на сьогодні заробітна плата, а точніше суддівська винагорода
суддів ВАСУ, прирівняна до суддів Апеляційного суду
і складає 40 прожиткових мінімумів для працездатних осіб.
До цієї заробітної плати, окладів
додається ще надбавки, які залежать від стажу роботи суддів.
Ваша особиста заробітна плата вона відрізняється від тієї,
яку Ви отримували на останньому місці роботи?
Станом на сьогоднішній день, коли суд не здійснює повноважень і судді теж,
ми не отримуємо надбавок
з травня по вересень 2019 року,
ми отримуємо тільки оклад і він складає без врахування податків 76 тисяч гривень.
Приємно, що на керівні посади починають обирати жінок.
Як почуваєтеся на новій посаді?
Мабуть, мені таланило в житті, і я ніколи   не відчувала
жодних проявів дискримінації за гендерним ознакою.
Тому і зараз, будучи обраною, я не привязувала це питання
до своєї статі. Зовсім.
Як ви бачите себе і ВАСУ через 5 років?
Хотілося б вірити, що за 5 років
рівень корупції буде настільки низький,
що потреби у ВАСУ не буде.
Пані Олено, чи розумієте Ви що можете увійти в історію України
як людина, яка за якою було посаджені люди,
які довгий час наживались на Україні,
чи відчуваєте на собі цю відповідальність. Історичну можливо?
Звичайно. Цю відповідальність відчуваю,
однак я б не стала персоніфікувати боротьбу з корупцією з моєю особистістю,
тому що в своєму статусі як суддя я є рівною з іншими суддями ВАСУ.
Пані Олено дякую Вам за інтерв’ю.
Дякую дуже.